thank you counselors
welcome along
uh we have
two or three apologies this afternoon uh
we have councillors doug grant and nick
grant and also councillor mcphail who
who won't be joining us today
both councillors grant well the two
grants
have been given me some thoughts on
various items that are on the agenda so
i'll share those when
when the time is appropriate
so to clear the meeting open
and just before i move on too much
further just a a big welcome to
caitlyn wright caitlin's the new face on
the side here and caitlyn's new into the
comms team and she's a digital com
specialist so she's looking after live
streaming and zoom this afternoon so
no pressure um caitlin
welcome
uh
okay we'll move on to item or yeah would
somebody like to move those apologies be
sustained please councillor bulger
secondary councillor phillips thank you
all those in favor please say aye
against the motion is carried
um confirmation or a declaration of
counsellor conflicts any conflicts that
counselors may have on the agenda today
they wish to declare
it's not thank you
so moving on to confirmation of minutes
and reports
so first one um well the only one
confirmation of the minutes the ordinary
meeting of council held tuesday 15 march
would somebody like to move that be seen
as a true and correct record please
councillor mcdonnell thank you dave
seconded councillor heisted
is there any alteration to the record be
needed if not i'll put the motion all
those in favor please say aye
against the motion is carried
thank you councillors
is there any urgent late business that
needs to be tabled now for discussion
there's not thank you
right which brings us to the first uh
real item of the day and um
it's a
an item on
three waters
and three waters reform update
and we have a report from the chief
executive obviously three waters is
probably the
the big controversy
discussion
up and down the country has been for
six or nine months and probably likely
to be for the next next six months but a
number of changes
are likely to
be undertaken as a result of the working
party and the recommendations that we
have included
in today's agenda but
firstly if i begin with a report from
the chief executive and steve do you
want to make any comments to that
i think we should look at really is open
to the council i just
endeavoured to
put my own view
of what the working group had come up
with
uh across to the council uh to help
perhaps set up a platform for debate
the
recommendations i said in my report in
the main make a lot of sense
and one has to wonder
where you've got a report that's
suggesting 47 specific recommendations
it does actually um
you do question how adequate the reforms
as um
released by the government uh fit in
terms of being such a purpose
i made a few observations there in
regard to
the need for the recommendation that
everything should be done by consensus
or worse at worst a 75 vote
um it does wonder i do wonder just how
effective that will be because not not
every debate
and this council has had those debates
where you can get a clear majority um
and
where you're looking for a
a reform to to make things better
uh from my observation it seemed to be
that those type of suggestions could
actually just hold
and restrain
needlessly the new entity from getting
on with its business
and so you worship early that's
this report has gone to the government
um
and the minister will be taking advice
and doubt from officials uh and will and
eventually i guess cabinet will then
announce uh its reaction to those 47
recommendations and how many of them
will find their way into the final
reform proposal
that will be the subject of legislation
thank you um steve and
my understanding is that the
reaction from government will be sooner
rather than later
and certainly the hope from across the
sector is that it'll be sooner rather
than later we need to make progress on
this
and i don't think there's been
absolute a claim by anybody or any
organization up and down the country
that the model put forward by the
government was a perfect one
we all know that change has to happen
and it's really just about what that
change looks like and how it um how it
translates into operation into the
future
and many of the comments that i that the
chief executive makes
i totally agree with i do have a slight
difference on the governance side of
things and i know that certainly
governance around a council table 75
majority would almost be an
impossibility uh absolutely but
certainly for most of the boards um or
any boards that i've been involved in if
you can't get 75 percent uh of the
people around the table uh on a
particular issue then you you probably
do need to rethink where you're going
and
with the regard to the co-chairing which
is something that is uh
certainly a new concept and and
challenging to particularly to people
with haircuts like mine um
but it is i'm on two boards now uh two
regional boards
uh one of them the just transit
transition authority and also the um
this the group that was set up by
cabinet to look into covered response
across the province
both of those have co-chairs and and
both work really well so
i don't have as much fear as as some
people may have around that issue but i
do acknowledge it's a big change
and it will be a a challenge in in some
respects
um
so look i'll open
um this item for discussion um
and or um receipt of the report or any
direction council would like to take on
this particular matter at this time
if there's no discussion no there is a
council of bulger
i i found a whole
whole thing extremely difficult to
follow you know
and to create the chief executive we're
really being given hobbs insurance by
central government and i had to have a
wee chuckle
in the narrative and not in your letter
but in the narrative surrounded by
central government there was going to be
efficiencies and money saved and i
thought
that's just not
you know
anybody with
some financial backing can see that that
is not going to happen it's going to be
particularly expensive um um we do need
uh government um input rate payer can't
fund what we have to do they're lifting
the bar so it's appropriate that we um
have some cooperation with government
that the the model they put it
put in front in front of us doesn't suit
me at all and i
think the um
the transit one or waka kaitoki one
would be the one that i'd still like to
see hammered away at but i guess we're
just inviting uh response from
government to our views aren't we and
although we've said that we'll cooperate
we're not uh
we're not
we still have a little bit of input into
what the result's going to be so uh
thanks for the letter steve but i i'm
just finding this extremely
difficult and some of the stuff from the
um
from the oversight group i found that
really
i have to say
somewhat focused on on
cultural issues rather than rather than
you know figuring out how to finance and
fund water and i found that
i asked myself
was this just my particular view or did
everybody else concerned about the
direction we weren't taking
well i felt we weren't taking so
i'll leave that and its
subtlety
um not too subtle um counselor bulger um
okay so
any further
council gatlin
you've just noticed there's quite a bit
of
feedback from the rural
perspective of rural water schemes and
um it'll be nice to think that the
government do take some response to that
because there is quite a difference
between the two different brackets
yeah absolutely and the um the working
party uh is cheered by um the mayor of
uh clutha on the rural water schemes and
i know that he's put his heart and soul
into um
pulling that group together
and from my understanding it's fair to
say that it's been a challenge
getting unanimity across that group but
but everyone that's on the group does
understand the importance of getting it
right
councillor heisted
thanks tracy i just have a question
about input from this council um we're
here to receive this report and it's
gone to cabinet is there a future
juncture where
councils will have a further input or is
the horse
i guess we'll have a input into the bill
will we yeah
council read and then councillor dixon
not for shout out problem
okay oh thank you your worship
so at this stage is there an opportunity
or does that come later for us to
actually
reiterate the idea of the
kotawi
partnership funding
as a preference
look i don't think there's any harm in
doing that and it would seem a separate
letter to
the minister
or the prime minister i guess
i think if we
were to
reiterate the the understanding we have
that reform does need to happen
we can't keep doing what we've been
doing
because we're just going to get more of
the same but we believe there is more
input for local communities than the
than the current model has
i well just i would like us to see that
happen so thank you okay
um
councillor dixon
thank you worship
um i just looking through this i was
quite concerned to see that there's only
one if the assets are put into shares
that we only get one vote for 50 000
people so
really gore
is is
not going to have a vote there and if
it's regionally we would only get two
votes and the north island would
have a heap of votes so that 75
then
makes it very difficult
and i guess that when you amalgamate
into whatever size the center entity
ends up as there's always going to be
that sort of challenge
but i know that quite a lot of work was
done on what is a workable model
um and actually
the
logistics of dealing with
more than
like if we had one should have mccarthyl
have three
um
once you get into those sort of realms
then in christchurch you might have
ten
um you you need a town hall for a
meeting
and that would be a real challenge so
um
understand your concern absolutely
but i'm just not sure that when you're
in a pretty much
a south island wide or definitely a
tucky wire wide model like we're looking
at now
how you could do that
you know i've two other comments too i
just think there's quite a few
insecurities around the funding the
government funding because of them
needing to get a lower interest rate for
the funding than we have now
so that that's another concern because
we they wouldn't have the assets either
for
collateral and we don't know anything
about the rma requirements at this stage
either which would have to fit into this
so
there's a lot of unknowns and a lot of
uncertainty
i feel
and certainly was you know there was
four 47 recommendations that came from
the working group those sort of things
are all picked up in in those
recommendations particularly the one
around the rma
and what any future
governance my law or planning and
governance might look like going forward
council phillips
thank you worship
once again it was right at the start of
my concern was about the cost and
to me there is absolutely nothing in
this report that tells me how much it's
going to cost each individual person
or
and this it's a major concern it was my
major concern right at the start
and yet again we're still getting this
analysis through here
and still no
definite figure of what it may cost
all right and
perhaps i'm being naive but um
we understand
where i understand anyway and i think we
as a council understand that things have
got to be done better we've got to have
a better standard
and we've got a better systems than than
we've had and and pretty much every
council is on exactly the same boat
to get those standards then that is
going to cost more money so where does
that money come from um that's the
challenge
any other comment we have from
councillors or questions
uh council read thank you your worship
back to uh councillor dixon's comment
about the voting
if gore
um
didn't have a vote per se would we be
working in the line along the lines of
the mural forum so that
our vote would come after consultation
with the other mayors in the district
i don't think
the
i don't think there's any similarities
the
the
formula that counselor dixon was talking
about is the is the governor's formula
and just
the um
the governance of the entity
um yeah so
can you explain it better than i can
just the chief executive
um i'll try do you wish
it's really about um
the
when you've got such a large population
so the um
the population for this three waters
entity d which is most of the south
island will be in the order of 850 odd
thousand
and we've got
12 and a half thousand people in the
goal district
that explains your dilution factor uh
in my view that the crucial aspect of
these reforms go ahead is the council
somehow developing a relationship
with the new entity at an important
level to ensure that it can advocate for
a service delivery on the ground
um
the voting
obviously that will be
important where these
big issues arise but i suggest that
the bigger issue will be trying to
maintain momentum and
improvement and service
while this reform process is unfolding
and the priorities that one of the key
things here is that the priorities that
the google district council has set
itself
for the last 10 years and three waters
we will with these reforms
be
on the outer and hoping just hoping that
somehow
the process can continue
at pace and so for example
the
stormwater separation program which
we're just commencing to elizabeth
street we know that we need to get that
stuff done
we have got probably the highest
percentage of
combined stormwater and sewer
network in new zealand
and logic would suggest that
this community should be a priority for
investment moving forward given the
strong environmental
outcomes that can be attained
but the trouble we'll have is
how do we influence
that program
in
uh competition with the likes of say
christchurch and dunedin i'm not picking
on them but just two larger urban
centers that's the issue
in my view
and
the funding that we've promised and
going back to council dixon's point you
can promise the funding will be made
available
uh but where does it come from and
councillor phillips what is the impact
to the individual rate path um
potentially there is some
upsides
but if you're a person in christchurch
with dunedin you might be thinking well
we could end up subsidizing a smaller
community
and to be brutally honest that has to
happen if the benefits that are being
espoused
to materialize
there there's no point pooling
a larger instinct if you can't actually
take advantage of that wider pool
and
standardize
costs and services within it
so um i'm just not i understand
everything you're saying i'm not sure
that answered counselor
bridge question about
where our voice would be
in that um
i'm struggling to find there's a there's
a graph on page or a diagram on page 101
in our
documents it sort of lays out quite
clearly where the various
parties sit in uh in the structure
and the the water services entity will
be the entity that actually does the
work that will be a board made up of
specialist people
who are
experienced and qualified in providing
the services that are required so the
regional representative group which is
the one we're talking about in terms of
where we sit as a
as a council having input into
we'll look at strategic direction and
setting this to
direction setting and and
oversight so it's it's quite different
to what
we currently we have
yeah
and that so that regional representative
group
oversees the
performance of the board and will
appoint a panel to appoint the board
and the report also talks about
sub-regional groups that's right
so what i'm saying that's what i say
about how complicated and constipated it
could be
and
for
reform you normally associate reform
with release and
liberation
not constipation
okay
uh counselor bulger and then counselor
phillips
indulge me again when i state the
obvious you know
bureaucracy layers upon layers upon
layers of bureaucracy to watch other
bureaucrats and the assumption by
central government is we don't know what
we're doing we know exactly what needs
to be done we just need the money that's
all we need we've got people on the
ground we have a
long-term plan we have a strategic and
engineering direction
all we need is the funding and that will
deliver the quickest result
for our community and and that's already
been done in in consultation with the
community and and erie and then the
principles of you know uh
good water quality are ensconced you
know these guys are reinventing the
wheel and um
you know
all my little spiel hasn't really
affected any change just made me feel
even better thank you
i don't disagree with anything you're
saying
at all
so how do we get our hands on the money
is the question yeah
um
phillips thank you i just got one other
thing that i think that we really need
to do and that's
to um
upgrade material water supply soon and
plant as soon as possible and i think
that should be a priority in the next
year or so that we actually physically
need to get that done
because look it could be if if we don't
get it done
um
we could be in it's taking a long time
certainly right at the top well right at
the upper level of the
of the priorities at the moment as well
yes absolutely uh the talking with three
waters manager getting the gore water
treatment project and matera water
signed off and completed before we
lose control to an entity is mission
critical
council
dixon
thank you worship i just have one
question
also about when and how we communicate
with our community with our ratepayers
on this
um well i guess that
this is part of that communication this
discussion now all this information is
is available publicly um and we'll make
that publicly available to anyone who
who wants it
i guess
the bottom line is we understand there
needs to be
change we don't totally agree with the
direction of the change
and
if we want to make
our objections known then we need to be
writing
to both the minister
and the prime minister i think to
express that as
as councillor bulger was it
councillor reed
shared before
okay if there's no further discussion
would somebody like to move along those
lines
that um we accept the chief executive's
report we accept uh the report from the
technical working group
um
we acknowledge the 47
recommendations
we
we disagree still with
the
the ownership model
and wish to reiterate our preference for
uh
a waka katahi
type model
okay move counselor davis seconded
council read thank you
right i'll put the motion all those in
favor please say aye
against the motion is carried thank you
councillors
certainly um there's probably been
nothing in my time in local government
where
division
has been caused
as is the division that's been
caused here i the upset up and down the
country is um
is
is palpable uh in
the local government circles but also in
in communities
um we'll move on then to
item six and we have an update on the
district plan
summary of costs
and a
memo from the chief financial officer
um
okay so uh chief executive is going to
cover that
you think she wishes unfortunately uh
lorna is well unfortunately great for
her she's on leave
so this is uh arose out of a query from
councillor gardine at a recent kennedy
meeting about just i wanted to know
where
the
general direction of travel was in
regard to expenditure incurred in the
district plan project
needs to be emphasized i think we need
to put this into a context of a 15-year
benefit that generally you will get with
the review district plan
so as the report from lawn has
highlighted where there or there abouts
in terms of
our budget
we have quite a lot of expenditure
behind us in terms of these various
tranches of investigative work that has
had to be undertaken to prepare
a
district a review discipline
that will
be a scrutiny
but there's still a bit of work ahead of
us
the district plan group has just
recently very recently via email just
formulating it's formulated its views
around when it will be in a position to
promote a draft
reviewed plan to the council with an
invitation for public notification
um that is now going to occur
uh very early in the next council's
tenure the thinking was rather than
invite this council to adopt
a draft and notification and then have
the
consultation process running through
christmas and new year and it'll be
cleaner to
get
the committee's ducks all lined up in a
row and be ready to come to the council
replete with a comprehensive section 32
analysis which you have to do in
probably february next year so in terms
of costs moving forward
difficult to
give you a definitive view
we do have some money allocated in the
in the ltp for another
year's worth of investment
um that i think will be needed
we
through the the process there are some
studies that we have
not
decided to do at this point in time and
we'll only do it for example if we get
submissions on a certain point that
requires investigation
um
but
in total we're probably we're still
probably about
five hundred thousand probably um
just to just still to come before we
complete the process
and that uh answer that um line of
advice is qualified heavily on the basis
of as dependent upon how many ultimately
appeals
that are lodged against the decisions
that the council may take in response to
submitters so
district plans are not for the
faint-hearted the process is long
and the rights of participation are
strong
but i think the district planning
committee has done some sterling work to
get us into into a position to be able
to notify over the next um
eight to nine months
hmm counselor guard on you raised the
issue any comments you know it was good
to see the plan i'm just a little bit
scared if we have to get into
identifying indigenous areas
whether that'll blow out yeah
okay um
so would you like to move the report be
received council garden thank you move
council guard on secondary council make
to now all those in favor please say hi
hi
item yeah item financial report uh for
31 december
um
do you want to talk us through this or
who's going to do that
yeah thank you worship look we've got uh
jb cunningham
our
management accountants are with us as
well and jamie is available to answer
some questions uh i can say that
launae the cfo was pretty comfortable
with we were at at this point in time in
the
financial year there's obviously some
timing issues and they can be quite
heavily just distorted when you've got
large amounts of
external funding that we are
receiving this year particularly around
the stimulus funding for three waters
and the closing the gaps program um but
and also from my perspective just of the
financial
um
yeah as it's unfolded it doesn't appear
to be
horrendous like it doesn't appear to be
too much out of kilter with previous
years
albeit that we've got
a few gaps in staffing and there's some
contractor costs
and the district playing costs as we
just covered are extraordinary as well
but um again they've been they've been
planned for in the overall budget
okay um
jamie any comments you want to make
before we open it up
zero
okay
thank you um open for discussion john
just looking at the total revenue is
lower than budget by seven hundred and
eighty seven thousand
that that's money
um just looking at their base revenue
likes of rates and
service rates and services for the water
that will be up i suppose with increased
sections and increased
publish
yep
the race requirement isn't affected by
changes to the rating information
database throughout the course of the
year and what we do is we
with our budgeting activity the
long-term plan we define what our total
rates take is going to be we then divide
that by the rating base and we set the
rates so local government rating act
doesn't allow us to change the rates
part way through the year for a property
so that yield is pretty much on budget
it's slightly higher due to
the timing between calculating the rates
round about march and then setting the
rates in june so that growth would have
been captured which is why our rich
revenue is slightly up on budget but the
drop in revenue is due to the timing in
the
1.2 million dollar income for the shovel
ready project
okay
yeah thanks tracy um order and risk
committee received this report and um
you spend a bit of time working through
it and i guess really
with the with the phasing issues and
these extraordinary items that steve
pointed out it's really going to be
interesting in the in the march quarters
to see
um how it's all starting to land and
unfold but there's some real challenges
around the reporting module um i know
when i and
the team jamie have been putting a lot
of work into that so
um
you know this juncture i don't think we
can really do a meaningful you know
light for light comparison
on our base budget
okay
right um counselor gutter just just
going forward with um
meadow ridge and there's a lot of
sections been subdivided in the year
a lot of those sections must come on
stream
during the year
for raiding
and they must hand heavy to work out
your writing and then it must be sort of
an
addition of income come in somehow
it can't be averaged halfway through the
year
through your worship the
if you
subdivide part way through the year that
property cannot legally be rated until
the first of july following the
subdivision
and so at the first of july when we
actually do rate that subdivision we'll
have taken the new
budgeted rates requirement for the year
and divided it by the rate information
database which is now larger because of
the subdivision which means that there's
a growth factor that actually reduces
everyone else's rates requirement if you
like so if all things remained equal
there was no increase in the rate's
budget and we have that growth with the
subdivisions everyone's rates but we go
down a little bit
okay
um
counselor dixon thank you worship this
is just relating to finance and i'm just
wondering if the council could
strengthen their buy local policy
because a lot of our retailers and
manufacturers are finding the economic
climate quite difficult
i'm just wondering if we could have a
report practice on a procurement policy
and how we could strengthen our buy
local
theme
yeah
yeah i'll ask the chief executive but i
understand we did review it just
recently recently didn't we
yes you worship we did review it only
about on that on that particular
provision about 12 months ago but there
is a new procurement policy being
developed as we speak and that will go
to order and risk and at its next
meeting in may or june june
i think it might be june but at the next
meeting of the ordinance committee the
proposed procurement policy will be on
that agenda uh and that's a chance for
the council for wishes to to strengthen
the buyer local
provisions
i just feel there is some urgency
in this like it can't drag on for months
really
certainly the um the advantage is for
local people
um at the moment the way it's structured
so i'm
i'm just not sure what suggestions you
might have that would strengthen that
but it's very much
to the advantage of local people to get
business with the council
i understand that but i think we could
raise the cap
for the amounts that um
we look at buying local
yeah so that that was considered wasn't
it
yeah um
and
i'm just struggling to
recall off the top of my head what um
what the response was but i
i think and i'm pretty sure it was
laurene that spoke to this
um i think she made some comment that
given
looking at a whole lot of purchases
that actually lifting the
cap wouldn't have affected
um
or you know substantially lifting the
cap wouldn't have affected the local
purchase but like i
i need to go back in a block don't know
yeah the audit and risk means one june
but it will be focusing on the policy
around procurement as opposed to
necessarily the buy local
component is that right
so in terms of councillor dixon's point
should we just do something stupid bring
us up to date really the next council
meeting
can do yeah so would that help
counsellor
um okay um anything further from that
report
um
would somebody like to move that'll be
um received please counselor mcdonough
double secondary counselor bulger thank
you all those in favor please say aye
against the motion is carried
um we seem to be i'm not it's just me or
not but i'm out of sequence in my
numbers but um i've got the next item as
item
on my gender is item seven but it's
actually automate and mine not just me
um so elizabeth street uh street
separation
uh
a private property drainage
implementation plan and we have a report
from
a three waters asset manager and i
understand
matt uh is not with us today although i
think he's on zoom
you're fitting well are you matt
can't complain that's good
okay um
okay so uh a pretty big project um that
we're um
sort of on the cusp of rolling out
then it's certainly got to be obvious to
anybody
that
a lot is happening in the elizabeth
street area with the number of pipes
that are stored in various parts of the
proximity
um so
matt as best you can from zoom
do you just want to talk us through this
report and then we'll take it from there
obviously since the council made the
decision to
fully fund the
private property
component of the elizabeth street work
we've been
doing the work on how that decision will
be implemented
and
we
have developed
an agreement um that would be put in
place with each property owner
before the works were undertaken
and also developed a list of frequently
asked questions um that will hopefully
um
all of here who have been doing a pretty
similar project up in auckland so it was
really helpful to guide those documents
and the other thing that we've been
working on is
how we're going to procure
a contractor to undertake those works
um and i guess in short we don't think
that a traditional procurement process
where we engage one
large contractor to do the work is the
best approach
so we're proposing to set up a panel of
local plumbing contractors
that would then be invited to to price
small packages of work
and then
an assessment only proposed pricing um
before awarding it
if we think that pricing is unreasonable
then we get a second price
um
local contractors are very busy at the
moment and we think that if we go
through a tender process
um there's gonna be a lot of time spent
um putting together
pricing and things
for no guarantee of work and that could
potentially
put off
a lot of a lot of
public contractors when they're getting
work
just basically um
purely on
pricing it um
yeah
yeah happy to take any questions about
that
okay the thanks matt um before we open
it up for discussion steve do you want
to make any comment at all
okay
so um the item is open for comment and
or question from councillors
counselor
hosted thanks tracy yeah i think the
panel approach is a is a good idea um
how do you see that panel being selected
matt is that
open to all
all local
suppliers it can be only limited to
local in terms of
selection criteria just interested to
know how that might shape up
yeah so that's um
request for
proposals to be on that dependent
um and and certainly i think
being a local
would be a um
a couple of things that we've sort of
thought about
in terms of selection criteria is we
probably don't want too many contractors
on the panel because it could just
become a little bit difficult to manage
so we're thinking between three and five
contractors the right number
and also
probably
want those contractors to
have enough scale that they can
do
this package of work while also meeting
their other
clients requirements so
yeah a requirement to have
multiple staff rather than the smaller
sort of one band
plumbing companies
okay
any other thoughts from councillors
councillor heisted i just have another
question just on page 162 there's a
an item 16 change of ownership where an
owner is required to
to uh let a purchaser know that they
have these planned works would it not be
appropriate to stick this on the
building file so it's picked up in a
limb just about some braces
save embarrassment to council
yep good point
okay other questions um
council phillips thank you questions i
just
manager of the of the site for the whole
completion of the of the works
our project engineer
will i guess oversee the entire project
and be looking after all the
plumbing contractors
thanks matt it's a good report and quite
clear particularly the facts session
um i just wondering what if
there's a
like the property owner decides that he
doesn't like that particular
plumber what's the alternative then
is there an opportunity for them to be
able to select the particular plumber
that comes to their property
yeah i think that would be
going with reasonable
panel approach
we could um i guess
initially not nominated bummer
um
thank you that's good to know okay
councilmaker now
is
contractor and his
uh property is fortunately one of the
ones that's already separated so we
don't need to do any work in his
property
but i'm sure he might be interested in
doing some of the
okay um just uh some comments from um
councillor grant who
reinforces what matt's been saying is
unable to be here today because of the
pressure of work i presume plumbing work
um but he has made some thoughts around
elizabeth street stormwater uh i'll just
read those out there's a 12 month
warranty from the contractor installing
new pipes into properties good enough
for the council and the right part
i'd be happier if it was at least five
year warranty from the contractor with
laying services underground
12 12 months is too short for the value
of too short for the money we're
investing in this project on behalf of
ratepayers
as a territorial authority
i'd like to also to offer my experience
of 23 years in the trade to the building
inspection team if they need another set
of eyes and someone willing to climb
under houses to inspect that everything
is up to code so just a couple of
thoughts from from nick
so just a comment around the warranties
um matt do you
do you have any
comment on that
certainly
i guess
because that fosma period is reasonably
standard
on
occasions um
can
increase there
but essentially um i guess you pay a
higher price for that because the
contractor needs to
price the risk with a longer defects
liability period um
i could perhaps talk to the building
inspector um the building control
manager
um
but my understanding
is fairly standard and
i guess you if you increase it you're
likely to pay a higher price for it
okay
thanks matt
okay other questions or comments um
before we move to uh a resolution
um
okay if not would somebody like to move
the
that the report be received and
uh that the council established a panel
of contractors to undertake the
elizabeth street private property
separation as outlined above
councillor reed secondary councillor
mactanelle thank you
uh any further discussion
does not i'll put the motion all those
in favor please say aye
against the motion is carried thank you
right um item
the next one up item eight or nine um
investigation into the old hospital
um
and we've got a report from our
facilities uh admin manager um neil do
you want to make any comments you know
through your worship it was just in
regards to this site has been looked at
for different reasons including
subdivision
but surprisingly there was never any
preliminary site investigation actually
done even though it was on the hail list
with the environment south
so we have commenced and done a
preliminary site investigation but
um
as stated in the report a lot of
demolition materials buried on site
and to identify exactly what areas are
contaminated and to what extent
we will need to do
a detailed
site investigation
because whatever the levels of
contamination are
there may be ways around it that we
could use it for different reasons such
as subdivisions or parks etc
so until we actually get a secondary a
detailed site investigation done we
can't really move forward in any
direction on that site
so it looks fairly obvious that um this
report is required before we do go much
further
do you want to make any comments steve
just to reinforce your worship that
unless we know what we're dealing with
we really can't advance any plans for
use of that plant
okay
questions comment or
we need to move the motion that's
been recommended counselor heisted
yeah i think this is a
good
step forward we've got to definitely
understand um what we're dealing with
just
just query is it sufficient in terms of
the test bits
and samples being taken to
to take us to a residential
subdivision
there's different standards depending on
what the targeted use is so is this
report targeted taking us to residential
or is it the next step
this could possibly take us towards
that situation
this will identify exactly where those
tunnels are
what is in those tunnels
and
one of the main costs you may have
realized in there was
all drilling will be
suspected that it's going to be bringing
up asbestos along the way
the problem is and we could
we know that the tunnels were not along
this uh wiggin street frontage or even
the selfridge street except where the
nurse's home
was close to the street there
but
while the demolition was being done a
lot of materials were moved around by
excavators trucks
etc and so it's possibly lightly
contaminated
further afield
but whether that is just going to
require to take a scrape off
we don't know the stage
sorry i'm not i'm not anticipating the
outcome just that the report is
sufficient to deliver what you've said
in terms of
what the property can be used for yeah
thank you
okay um
somebody like to move the recommendation
or providing you one councillor reed
seconded counselor garden
all those in favor please say hi
motion is carried thank you
um
right we'll move on then to the minutes
of ontario community board
we have minister community board
held on 28 march
and
we need to recommend that they be um
received and recommendations contained
within them ratified or changed so um
or discussed um
do you
think you wish um what you'd see i
wasn't
present at that meeting i had another
meeting to go to um
i've been since talking to any of the
board members quite uh happy to ask
answer any questions that might be
if not um i can move that report okay
but first of all i'd just like to thank
the staff who erected the fence
line along river street
it's a really good job
i asked the question at the start with
environments health and whose
responsibility it was
and hence defence has gone gone up
at the gorgeous council's cost but i
once again asked the question who is
responsible for for holding back the the
safety of the of the people from the
river river edge
um
it will be interesting to see exactly
who's is responsible
because it's currently at air cost
where it should be i think in my mind
environment southland's cost
cause i guess there's a risk that the
fence might need to be replaced at some
point in time too
yeah that's correct
so
okay and do you have a comment on that
steve any thoughts around areas of
responsibility between the regional
council and the tla
with regard to river boundaries
uh not
not a lot of clarity you worship i
sometimes think that you can either
invest a lot of time saying it's your
role and it's not our role
versus just saying look there's a
there's an issue here it's pressing get
in do it and and fix it and i guess
that's the
stats view has been
because
even if it was the regional council's
role and i'm saying even if
they the council may cite
budgetary constraints as to or lower
priority whatever
and we've been none the wiser and i'm
always reminded of the
the project
almost 20 years ago now with a
roundabout at the foot of the gore
bridge
and
the people today said it's not a council
role it should be
nzta should fund it exclusively but the
reality was that if we rely on ngta but
still wouldn't have a roundabout
and the council day just got it and did
it
as a as a contribution to making a far
more functional uh and safe
running network and the fence
along the material river is a similar
case a point i think
it's pretty pragmatism
yeah thank you where's a better but um
once again it depends upon on your point
of view to me i pay rates to both
councils
and the aspect is that whose
responsibility is it should i have to
pay because i'm a right partner of the
goal district which i have to pay
because i'm in a rate by environments
now
and uh yeah we could stand here and
probably argue that all day but as you
say
thank you for the
work that the reserves department have
done
they've made the residence of matera
safe and i appreciate that
thank you
right
okay um so you're you're moving that
motion council
yeah
council bulger
okay
seeing as that
fence was required because of the
erosion and it had something to do with
the build-up of the island does anybody
know what's actually happening if
there's going to be ongoing removal or
are we stalled in the meantime
can i answer that question in your issue
um the community board have um asked for
a meeting with uh local reno
and
yeah that's an ongoing
question about what's going to happen
so
it's a it's a an issue i don't have a um
an answer to but what is environment
south and stance
on
the build up in that particular area
well the person that made the report to
the local community board at their last
not last meeting but the meeting before
no longer works for uh no longer works
with them so
it'll be afresh basically start again
okay so it's a work in progress for the
community board
it is okay just why not meeting you
russia
right thank you
so are you sickening that russia you
will god thank you
mr bulger just before um to finish up i
just
like to
point out about
the donation given by the local
community board to
the snaps program in matera and
it's with the gratefulness that we've
um issued 500 to their to that project
of spading the local
animals the wild animals that she traps
and she does a sterling job and that was
their response to the program that
that the cat
society as i'm going to call them
have one of the initiatives to come
forward
thank you
okay great
thank you
thank you i just have a query here i
wonder if mr thakur would be happy to
pick up white where from
the gore
transfer station as well
um i think we need to get rid of the
stuff that's in matera first worship
because it's once again it's like the
trees
now that the trees are gone it's more
visible behind as you're traveling along
state highway 1 through matera so
i'm mindful when i look left and see the
transfer station i can see the big pile
of white stuff that's sitting over there
that should be actually
chipped up or demolished or taken away
and
and thanks to
mr mia i think he's doing his best to
try and rectify that issue
yeah
neil do you want to make your comment
yes
please thank you through your worship
um the situation with whiteware is that
any transfer stations around southland
um
the scrap metal merchants will not
coming up to the transfer stations it's
not worth it while as far as costs go
if it's delivered into the invercargill
yards
um they'll pay about 320 dollars for
straight metal
and about 200 for white wear a tongue
um you don't get too many ton of white
water in a in a truck though
unfortunately so the freight costs can
kill it
what
has is happening with the moment with
through the bond contract who is
responsible for the white ware they've
done a test in the windale
transfer station
and the white white wear and other metal
has gone through a chipper
and which
so they can get a good volume into a
skip
truck and take it down to the script
yard
the cost of the chipper is fairly
expensive but
by taking just clean metal down to the
yard they're getting a good price so
it's counteracting bond
i delayed bond into just coming into
gore because we had the chipper on site
doing green waste
because there was no guarantee that any
cost was going to come back to us
because when they do white wear
all the plastic and bits and pieces get
put aside and then it goes over the
trench
through the trent via the transfer
station over to winton
so
that is then the next added cost to us
as well
so i've basically had a guarantee from
bond that it will not cost
war district council anything to do this
so they're going to start but matera is
not under the bond
contract
so
at the last
material community board mentioned it
was
mentioned about mr thaker so i said well
if he notifies contacts me which he has
not done as yet
we need to just have it in in writing as
to what
he's um going to do
so that we're not given anybody just
a free hand of helping themselves to
anything that's in the in that yard
there so we're working it through
hopefully with the material community
board to get rid of the terror but gore
will start
going down shortly
okay it sounds like good initiative and
i guess
we'll make progress
um
so we have a motion anything further
before i put the motion all those in
favor please say aye
motion is carried thank you
next item on the agenda's local
government conference which
this coming year is being held in
palmerston north
and
interestingly looking at some of
the items on the
on the agenda
uh certainly a lot of items that have
occupied
some of the time that we have around
this council table as well about just
what the future looks like um which
in my mind has never been
more uncertain for local government
than it is is right now
okay so um
look the um the item is up for
discussion from councillors but um
essentially if uh
if there's a counselor that's
interested in going then there's an
opportunity
everybody's looking at the floor
palmerston north in the winter
okay
cancer radios are deep in the mirror i
don't think you've been to a local
government conference
um
it's great to get that voluntary
response from uh from councillors
okay
so at this point it looks like um deputy
music
um
so somebody like to move along those
lines council bulger i can see him
jumping at the chance
and councillor macdonald thank you
um
so with um that that decision was
somebody like um
somebody like to move the
recommendations please
move councillor dixon seconded
councillor heister
all those in favor please say aye
against the motion is carried thank you
councillors
i can assure you they're riveting um
um so issuing staff warrants
and we have a
uh memo here from just you
um
right
so reasonably straightforward as chibi
said if you want to make any comment at
all no
okay
move council davis secretary councillor
phillips
uh all those in favor please say aye
against the motion is carried thank you
um and uh opportunity to
be a member on a subcommittee or by law
review
um
public consultation draft on the gorge
to council cemeteries bylaw
and
we need
two councils right are we looking for
two councillors here
yeah two or three
so anybody got a particular
interest in this
i guess we've all got an interest at
some point in time
okay thank you councillor heisig good
and councillor reed jeepers and
councilmaker now thank you we have three
oh dear
okay um
so with those names added i'll put that
motion all those in favor please say aye
against emotions carried
i did anybody move that motion
did you
don't think of it
got a bit ahead of myself there so move
counselor guard on secondary council
phillips
again i'll just put it all those in
favor please say all right against the
motions carried thank you
right um i think that brings us to the
end of our open agenda so thank
councillors um
for their attendance to this point but
i'll move that the public be excluded
from the following parts of the
proceedings of the meeting namely the
items listed below the general subject
of each matter to be considered while
the public